字幕: Mizuho WATANABE
校正: Kazunori Akashi
今日はですね
ちょっとデザインの話をしたいと思います
TEDの「T」と「E」と「D」
意味 知ってますか？
「テクノロジー」
「エンターテインメント」
「デザイン」です
今日は私「D」を
担当させていただきます
よろしくお願いします
ちょっと最初の方で座らせてもらいます
今日は私が最近見て一番感動した
デザインというのを
ちょっとお持ちしましたので見てください
この中のどこがデザインか分かりますか？
この真ん中のとこですね
ここです
普通の立体駐車場は
こういうバーがついています
その下を通って
上がつっかえると入庫できなくて
そこが通れれば行けるんですけども
いつもこういう所を通るたびに
絶対に大丈夫だって分かっているのに
すごく緊張してしまいます
そういうことないですか？
（笑）
このタイプの
初めて見ました
これは札幌の
ある立駐なんですけれども
上から―
チェーンがついていて
そこを通っても
揺れるだけという感じです
ボールが先についてるんですけれども
こういう形だと
とても こちらも緊張しないで
入れることができます
私がここの何に感動したかというと
よく見てください
このボール
素材がスポンジで出来ています
スポンジで出来ているので
仮にその下を高級車が通って
擦ったとしても
それが傷つかないわけです
そういう配慮に私はすごく
感動してしまいまして
愛を感じまして
「すごい！これは面白い！」と思って
写真を撮りまくりました
かなり怪しい人でした
で その日の午後は
なんかすごい いいこと
考える人いるなぁと思って
とっても幸せな気分になりました
「これがデザイン？」って
思うかもしれません
そうです
これはデザインです
まず 使い手に対する配慮
それから―
それに対する
すごく新しい
いいアイデアで解決しています
そして その上
完璧な素材の選択
これはもう まさしく
私が思うデザインの
素晴らしい例だと思っています
あまりに このボールが
好きになり過ぎちゃって
そのあと２回ぐらい
駐車場を使いました
（笑）
つまりこの会社は
デザインで成功している会社というふうに
言えるかもしれません
はい
みなさんはデザインって聞いて
どういうことを思い浮かべますか？
ちょっと思い浮かべてみてください
例えば―
おしゃれなデザイン家電
デザイナーズマンションとか
それからデザイン雑貨
それから―
かっこいいスマートフォン
こういうもの
頭に浮かべると思います
私は初めて会う人に
「職業は何ですか？」って言われて
「デザイナーです」って言うと みなさん
「へぇー かっこいいですね！
デザイナーさんですか！」
なんて「さん」までつけて
言ってくれたりとか
あと 高校の同級生なんかは
「すごいね
儲かってんでしょ？」って
言ったりします
開業医がそんなこと
私に言ったりするんですね
（笑）
それから―
大学で工学部の学生を
教えてるんですけども
その子たちも
「えー僕 実はデザイン
ちょっと分かんないんです」
「正直言って苦手です」という人たちが
たくさんいたりします
どうやら デザインっていうのは
一般の人から見ると
ちょっと遠い世界の話みたいに
思ってるみたいです
何かすごい専門的な
スーパークリエイティブの
そういう人たちが
すごい能力を持って
仕事をしている世界っていうふうに
映っているみたいです
デザインっていうのは
遠いものなのかなーと
思っていますが
そんなことはありません
デザインは私達の周りに
すごくたくさんあります
で あまりに近すぎて
それが見えなくなっているんだと思います
今日はせっかくなので
みなさんに
デザインの面白さとか
身近なものに目を向けてもらって
デザインとの距離を縮めてもらえたらな
っていうふうに思っています
どういうふうにやるかっていうと
ものの見方を変えて
デザインとの距離を縮めよう
というふうに 今日は思っています
まずですね 私がどうして
こういうことをやるようになったか
きっかけです
これは私の両親なんですけれども
私の両親はデザイン好きの
美術教師でした
私が３歳の時に札幌の平岸
というところに新居を建てまして
もう張り切っちゃって
頑張り過ぎのインテリアですけれども
北欧にかぶれていて
360円が１ドルの時代に
手荷物で いろいろなものを
フィンランドやデンマークから買ってきて
それを使って
私も使わされ―
こんな 暮らしを―
強要されていました
（笑）
そんなこともあって
だんだん そういう
デザインに対してなんとなく関心を持って
育ってきました
時は経ち高校生になったとこです
高校に入ったところ―
まずいきなり
成績が非常に悪くなってしまいまして
美術以外は
ほとんど「２」「３」
ちょっと良くて「４」みたいな
そういう感じでした
ほとんど一点豪華の美術
それから家庭科
体育
それから行事
こういうものだけが得意な人に
なってしまいました
そうすると学校に行くのも面白くないので
学校が早く終わると
名画座に通い映画と
ロック三昧というですね
典型的な
落ちこぼれな感じだったんですけども
その頃 世の中では―
日比野克彦さんという
デザイナーがデビューしたりして
グラフィックデザイン・ブーム
っていうのがありました
私もミーハーなので
じゃあ私もグラフィックデザイナーに
なりたいなーとか
思っていたんですけれども
それで美術の方に進学しようと思いました
で―
１年間の浪人を経まして
無事 東京の美術の学校に入りました
そこではインテリアのデザインを
勉強したんですけれども
時はバブル—
こういうですね
奇抜なデザインが
もてはやされた時代です
すごくデコラティブで
材料もすごい高いものを使って
奇抜なものを作るっていうような時代でした
で 学校を卒業して
ちょっと
ぶらぶらもしてたんですが
26歳の時に
デンマークに家具の勉強を
しに行こうということで
留学することになりました
これです
その当時 今のような
北欧ブームじゃなくって
デザインの学生はみんな
イタリアのミラノに
留学したがっていた時代でした
なので デンマークの国の中で
たぶん―
全部の留学生を入れても10人も
いなかったんじゃないかと思います
美術のほうは たった３人でした
そこのところで―
２年間 デザインの勉強を
したんですけれども
その時に分かったのが―
デンマークという国のデザインは
生活に根ざした
モノづくりをしていて
デザインっていうものが社会の中で
いろんな役割を果たしている
そうですね
何かこう問題があると
それをデザイン的に改善するというか
そういうことが行われてる国でした
バブルの日本から行った私は もう本当に
あまりに違って結構
びっくりしてしまったんですけれども
そこに大変 共感をし
影響を受けました
で これがデンマークデザインの
精神を言っている
ひとつの本だと思うんですけれども
『デザイン：それは問題提起から始まる』
良い問題を見つけることが
良い解決法を導くことです
そういうところに目を向けて
デザインをしていこうという考え方です
それは「問題提起型のデザイン」という
言い方ができると思うんですけれども
こういう考え方が一般の人にも
非常に浸透している社会でした
そこが日本とすごい違うなと
思ったんですけれども
その一般の人が
デザインを理解していることが
とても素晴らしいなと思い
私も じゃあ日本に帰ったら
そういうことしてみたいな
というふうに思っていました
ところが帰ってみると
日本はバブルがはじけてまして
ちょうど92年から94年ぐらいの時に
いたんですけれども
状況が変わっていました
でもやっぱりそういう
問題解決型のデザインっていうのは
あまり今ほどは
語られていませんでした
せっかく張り切って
帰ってきたのですが そこで―
うっかり―
間違ってフリーランスに
いきなりなっちゃったんですけれども
そういうことに―
まぁ 結構ショックを受けて
５年間ぐらいはデザインをするっていうのが
全然楽しくない時期がありました
その頃からやっぱり
一般の人にデザインっていうものを
分かってもらえる機会が欲しいな
というふうに いつも思っていました
今日はせっかくなので
みなさんに ちょっとデザインのことを
知ってもらうことを考えました
デザインと近づくために
ある方法を―
今日から実践できる
とてもTED的な
内容を ちょっと考えてきました
いいでしょうか？
（拍手）
それは―
「デザイン視力を強くしよう」
っていうことなんですね
デザイン視力っていうのは
私が勝手に作った言葉なんですけれども
身の周りをよく見て
デザインの種になるものとか
デザイン的なものっていうのを
もっとキャッチする感性を
みんなで磨こうよ ということです
とても簡単なので―
早速やってみたいと思います
いいですか？
それでは この会場を見回してください
この中にデザインは見つけられますか？
２つぐらい見つけてもいいです
もっとでもいいです
いいですか？
じゃあみなさん
「せーの！」で 指さしてください
いいですか？
せーの！
結構バラバラですね
（笑）
ここ結構―
この辺とか結構多いですね
ありがとうございます
あっちもありますか はい
今日この後ろの背景は
北翔大学の学生さんたちが
デザインしてくれました
もうホントに
TEDを盛り上げるいい感じの
デザインですよね？
（拍手）
それから 私が好きなのは
このロゴなんですけれども
このTEDのロゴすごいかっこいいです
うっかり今回のスピーチを
受けてしまったのは
このロゴがカッコ良すぎて
「うわカッコいい！」みたいな
自分もちょっと良くなっちゃった みたいな
そういう誤解がありまして
うっかり受けてしまいました
じゃあ次に
視力を強くする秘策を伝授しますので
みなさんやってください
小さい声か 心の声―
ちっちゃい声で言いますかね
これから言うことをやってください
いいですか？
じゃあ「すべてのものは
誰かが作ってる」って
小さい声で言ってください
（囁く声）
（小声で）あっすごい
はい
世の中のすべてのモノは
誰かが作っています
当たり前っていえば
当たり前なんですけれども
自然界にあるもの以外は
この世の中に最初からあるものなんて
何もないんです
例えば―
一番デザインと遠そうなもの 何かな？
暗幕
［暗幕］も誰かが作ったんですね
床なんかもすごく
デザインされてるものですね
ネジとか
文字とか
それからボタン
服のボタンもそうですね
それから道のカーブ
こういうことも
誰かが考えているわけです
誰かがデザインしてるというわけです
デザインっていうのは
そもそもは「計画」とか―
「設計」っていう意味がある言葉なんです
誰かが作っているということを
意識して世の中を見てみると
前よりも多く［デザインを］
感じられるんじゃないかと思います
じゃあちょっと もう一回そういう視点で
この部屋を見てみてください
どうでしょうか？ さっきよりも多く
デザインが見えてきましたか？
どうですか？
そうですね？
確実に３分前よりも
みなさんデザイン視力が上がっています
即効性があります
で これは―
夜空の星が最初は明るくて
見えないんだけれど
ジーっと見ていると
見えるようになりますよね？
そんな感じで だんだんこう
デザイン視力が上がってくると思います
じゃあ デザイン視力が強くなると
どんないいことがあるか
３つあります
１ 単純に面白い
世の中を見る目が ちょっと変わると
とっても楽しいことがたくさんあります
例えば そうですね
好奇心の幅が広がって
見えてる風景が違ってきます
これは―
札幌市の中央区にある街路灯です
みなさん街路灯に注目したことありますか？
たぶん今日からバスに乗ると
街路灯が気になって仕方なくなると思います
（笑）
それから 身の回りの美しさに
気づくことができるようになります
例えば自動車っていうのは―
本当にデザインのエリートのような
人たちがたくさん集まって
何十人もかかって 何年もかかって
作るものです
この外形は実は粘土を―
クレイという粘土を
手で削って作っている
手作りの彫刻品なんですね
彫刻作品なんです
そういう目で世界を見てみると
あのうるさくて邪魔だった
道路の自動車が
街が美術館のように見えてきませんか？
しかもタダです
２番目
デザインのメッセージを
受け取れるようになる
デザインには 作り手は
プロフェッショナルだったり
そういう人たちが―
専門家が長い時間をかけて
それから心を込めて作っています
どんな小さいものでもそうです
例えば
もっと使いやすくしたい
ゆったり座ってほしい
それから―
未来を
表現しようぜみたいな
そういうメッセージとかいろいろあります
で そういうものが
だんだん受け取れるように
なってくるはずです
例えば みなさんの手元にあるようなハサミ
このハサミの柄の部分の
このアール
これは使い勝手が良くなるように考えた
形が表現されたものです
つまりデザイナーや作り手が愛情を持って
作った結果なんですね
つまり―
デザインっていうのは愛なんです
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
様々な課題も
見えてくるようになると思います
身近な いろいろなことを
観察することによって
さっき言った
解決すべき問題の種っていうのが
いろいろ見えてくるように
なってくると思います
これはとても小さな例なんですが
私が作ったバターナイフです
こういうものです
これは友達とのパーティーとか
宴会のときに
バターを塗ったあとの
ナイフ―
「一体どこに置けばいいの？」って
感じることはないですか？
「こうやってやんのかな？」
「この人のとこかな？」
で それを解決するために
「真ん中に立てちゃえばいいじゃん！」
ということで
みなさんの真ん中に置いて
これが共有のものになる
そして何となくテーブルも
にぎやかに楽しくなる
そういう結果になりました
これも小さな観察をすることによって
出来上がったデザインです
もうデザイナーが―
部屋にこもって ひとりで
デザインする時代っていうのは
もう終わりました
もう一般の人たちが
いろんな形でデザインと関わることによって
モノを作ったり
社会を作っていったり
それから地域のコミュニティを
作っていくっていうふうな
時代になってきています
つまり―
「みなさん自身が社会のデザイナー」
なんですね
はい
（拍手）
私はプロですが
みなさん―
“Beyond the Border”
（垣根を越えて）いただいて
いろんなことを一緒に
作っていけたらいいなと思います
で 社会のいろいろなことっていうのを
良くするために
デザインをツールとして使う
可能性っていうのは
まだまだたくさんあると思っています
それでまず―
まずは小さなところから始めてください
「デザイン視力を良くして―
世界の見方を変えていきましょう！」
というのが今日のお話です
ありがとうございました
（拍手）